today's topic lily sink now we've heard
a lot of people criticizing girls but
all over YouTube people been hating on
her rocks say to the flower ok bloomer
skinny jeans favorite jeans mom jeans
like a dope genuine son Golden Snitch is
from a game in Harry Potter and they're
the smallest balls in the game I got the
travel size because I can't imagine your
tiny piece wouldn't need any more than
that YouTube comments so I thought we
could take a minute out of tonight's
show to have a computer read a few of
them
well I dance comment think is literally
the worst thing I have ever seen
who gave her this show it would have
been perfectly fine on YouTube for
anything that isn't TV I think it's uh I
get all the youtubers you're palling on
her they're all like oh my god she's so
unfunny she's so unfunny I think they're
going about this the wrong way the fact
that she's unfunny or not is irrelevant
at the end of the day an opportunity was
offered to her and she jumped on it and
the reality is she's not qualified for
it but that's not her fault that's the
people who booked her she just took the
opportunity exactly when I go to a
comedy show and the comedian is booked
to headline and the comedian sucks I'm
not mad at the comedian I'm mad at who
booked her cuz they're the ones who made
the final call to have that person there
for you guys to get mad at her to me so
asinine it's like of course she sucks
she's never done comedy how is she going
to be good at this what you guys are
watching is an open mic err on national
television every week bad scripts that
fits her narrative on coda stand-up
comedy open mics every week I watch
first-timers they sound just like her
the only difference is the only
difference is she gets applause breaks
all the time so she thinks her contents
could and Plus even worse is that she's
got a core group of Wyatt riders now who
are right for its corn is terrible is
but it's not surprised yo you put our
you should have the delivery of an open
mind girl oh yes
I've met 10 of her at open mikes yeah
well girls will go up on stage and do
these in like holier-than-thou
monologues about social justice that
they figure it's not money
and the Collings is just like huh and
you'll hear some girls be like yeah shut
up
yeah but is the same business same thing
but that she has she has Oh laughing
tracks the laughs are the same it's not
over yet so it's on top makes it worse
insulting it makes it worse Bravo if I
was doing an open mic every week in
front of national television I would
suck too if that's how you learn yeah
I'm not mad at her mad at NBC for
putting together a [ __ ] show
15 million subscribers my house their
talk show host or comedian would even
think about talking like no one wants to
hear people brag about how much money
they make there's nothing comedic or
Helen at all special talking about how
she much got money so that's it see the
talk-show host and she so that's not
very true
Dave Chappelle routine these ain't jokes
yeah how much money he makes so that's
not really true
listen that don't have to be relatable
you just have to have an interesting
perspective I think that was the name of
our show - what relatable when it was
laughing about the fact that she's not
relatable 9 but you know I'd understand
that in Ellen's defense like it was all
it was actually like a context right she
was actually laughing the fact that
people are saying that comedy has to be
relatable therefore because she has a
lot of money she's not relatable social
was talked about a whole lot of money
there was a context of that but still I
mean comedy does not have to be
relatable how many times do I hear
people who live lives that are
completely crazy to me and foreign and I
find their perspective and their lived
experience fascinating it doesn't have
to be relatable to me it can still be
interesting and form again this
a youtuber now who doesn't do stand-up
comedy who's trying to tell people what
comedy supposed to be bro I do comedy
you're not close to it so the same way
that Lilly Singh is out of her depth
when she does stand-up comedy
this youtubers also added his death when
he tries to provide you guys with
insight on what comedy is supposed to
look like one money's gonna practice it
more research about it 15 seconds in now
not even that and that and that is that
is to you that is see whenever someone
says like they want to bring an argument
and saying like and on top of that it's
not even funny I haven't laughed for a
whole minute I know people like that how
many times have I done shows right and
you see everyone laughing and there's
that one person will be like mmm and
then at one point during a quiet she's
just like this shows not funny
leave he's not funny to you yeah
laughter is contagious the fact that you
can sit in a room full of people and not
laugh means that you're probably a
sociopath that's your problem we're
immune or dead inside that's you That's
not me
there was a critic a comedy a comedian
critic and a comedy critic and the
newspapers were saying well I saw this
show and everybody else was laughing but
I didn't find it funny that's what was
not funny well then you could say that
it was not for you you're not the target
audience
yes but claiming that something is not
funny because you didn't laugh saying
something it is not funny is not you're
not you're not into clearly indicating
the subjective component to that
statement if you say it's not funny to
me that's fine yeah when you see
something is not funny you're saying it
as if it's a fact preach is white or I
could say to me preachers away that's
different
what Nate I am white well judging by how
much you hate black women you saw that
[ __ ] it was something that you know my
dudes what my dude my mind one of mine
did my mans were said to me who are
having discussion different
people that were funny or not know any
was saying I don't think he said that I
don't think that person is funny but you
know you got a respect to laugh meaning
I was in the room many times with that
person I didn't think it was funny but
you have to respect people were on the
ground right but I don't think this [ __ ]
was fun right so you got to respect to
laugh Ram it is what it is so I don't
think something is funny it doesn't mean
[ __ ] doesn't mean nothing it's like me
watching a video on YouTube you know
this is not entertaining it's not an
indication of your skill level you may
appeal to specific items the same way
Lilly Singh and her corny ass YouTube
videos appeal to a specific line it's
she's built a large brand so I just
don't understand why people are
continuously trying this whole she's not
funny I'm not laughing it doesn't matter
like you guys your arguments are so bad
you have me here defending the singer
well I didn't like it oh that's crazy I
don't think anybody would have a problem
with it but her and her team made the
big mistake of just making it all about
that making it all about her being a
woman of color like look at me and I
move over move over white people it's
it's um it's the brown woman's gain now
I mean most people do that guys make a
lot of their comedy about being a dude
when they're starting out almost every
open Micro I know goes about their
identity to try to do comedy because
it's like Asians come up on stage and do
Asian jokes awkward guys do awkward
people jokes like every time I've gone
to open mics every joke is always about
self and identity always I mean because
you start with what you know so what is
she gonna talk about that she knows is
interesting to other people that she can
probably extrapolate from her identity
I'm not saying it's good I'm not saying
it's funny I'm saying it's just common
go to an open mic
what you're seeing is multiple Lilly
sings going up all night and one funny
guy
well my first bit was about me and my
girl I had to because it was that's what
I know but my first five minutes was
about race and my name yeah but you know
if your name is a bird you don't joke
about that [ __ ] I don't know who you are
Oh but now that I've progressed I've
obviously moved on to different topics
outside of myself but just like you said
she does operate like an old man
yes and and what about writers like what
were you looking for in writing you sort
of wrote by yourself for all these
leaders for eight years I was writing my
own stuff and now I have a writers room
which is fantastic I just need to humble
brag for a second because I think it's
very important I want I was very adamant
on having an inclusive writers room
that's very important to me so it was
over 50% women and people of color so
not so not not good writers not writers
that are based on meritocracy writers
that are gonna go with my views if you
want the best product you hire the best
people I don't mind that she had a lot
of women I don't mind that she had you
know less man I don't mind that she had
people of color my problem was like
meeting a 50-50 quota to me it seemed
more like you guys needed to have this
specific selling point so that when you
guys were gonna market this show was
meant like I could tell her publicist
talked to her before I had to mention
the fact that it's 50/50 because we knew
on a cell that NBC is promoting a
diversity talk show were the first of
its kind
you could tell these are like talking
points that they were worried about in
terms of the marketing rather than
making sure that content was really
solid and I think they're making a lot
of mistakes with how they're producing
the show tremendous amount of mistakes
if there are more focus on the
appearance of it rather than what's on
the inside which is what really matters
it looks inclusive yeah includes a lot
of doodoo I think some tips that Lily
you could take when it comes to this
stuff but I don't know your mansplaining
better better integrate your YouTube
into this whole thing I think you have a
huge platform that you guys could be
utilizing to really cross promote the
two and I felt like basically you just
left you two sphere you jumped into this
talk show sphere and you haven't
utilized your platform adequately from
what I'm seeing well I think I think
you're trying to fit the format of talk
show way too much if you're going to be
different and special don't just do it
at face value don't just do it because
oh it's a brown girl oh it's a bisects
like that's it doesn't matter make sure
that the content and the way you're
presenting the show is drastically
different you look like every other talk
show host except you're a brown woman
the format is identical
uninteresting the only difference is you
do it way worse than them so why would I
watch you when there's nine other people
doing it far better than you and they're
way funnier what do you mean by
including more of her YouTube that form
well the way she did the YouTube thing
is like she had a lot of like really
good sketches that look really good
let me preface this by saying I don't
like them but I understand that they're
well done in terms of hitting her market
she did all that stuff she wrote it
herself so you could tell it was closer
to who she was when she does those jokes
and I hear them I could clearly tell is
written by somebody else and everything
is specifically time and it looks
awkward you watch her old videos and you
could actually see that okay there's
some fluidity to it
yeah you know there's something genuine
about it exactly so she's gotten so much
into the realm of like I'm gonna follow
this format like no go back to some of
the YouTube stuff I made you care of it
I do I do TV now the biggest youtuber i
think is david dobrik right now okay
nice huge subscriber base all that stuff
with all his following he went to
Netflix and say yo can I do a show with
you guys I have a really great idea
and they're like not interested because
the perception of youtubers is
inherently negative and so I'm like if
you guys want that to change
you should be encouraging or if not
you're not gonna encourage don't water
your weed ain't want people who may have
an opportunity to take this platform to
the next level well something I
understand what you're saying but it's
just that she doesn't the perception is
why I think they hate it's because of
the perception of how she's doing thing
is not humble it doesn't look like and I
don't know it's just jokes and it's just
written stuff I know that but I
understand certain people's like you
know you have a certain cockiness to it
I don't care about it because I know
that what's on video I'm not gonna try
not to judge I try to lessen less to
judge what I see on the video and judge
a whole personality of someone from what
I see on a video but the delivery of
what she does and how she does it
it looks very cocky so people are just
it's a defense mechanism for them to
know it's like to Humble someone we like
we
see someone I was very cocky like yo you
ain't [ __ ] calm down you're not better
than all of us I just I'm just saying
that's what I see right now is it better
is it good is it good to do that let's
say no I don't think it is but I
understand where it's from and why
they're doing it
sure I wouldn't I wouldn't disagree but
it's still stupid fair like what you're
gonna get you're gonna scream at someone
who's being cocky and cost yourself
future opportunities June I mean don't
even think they see it like that yeah
because they're not seeing the bigger
picture Yeah right
they just see an instant video that I
can hate on Lilly Singh cuz she's
unfunny to my subjective opinion I'm
like what's the point of this whole
house is productive mmm you're gonna go
tell everyone what comedy looks like no
you don't get to say what it looks like
that's not you don't get it especially
if you're not in the realm you certainly
don't get to say what it looks like
but even neat I'm not gonna go out of my
way to define it for you because I see
comedy of all forms stuff I will never
laugh at and I still book it on my shows
if it makes audiences laugh because it's
not about what's funny to me when I book
a show when I curate something I'm
thinking about the public what is funny
for them that's it you have to respect
the laugh that's it and what you guys
have to do is respect the fact that
you're Lilly's successful she's
successful and there's an audience who
likes what she does and if she's going
to a new platform it's not going well
that's okay you don't have to support
her in that situation but don't let her
go way to trash her cuz it's not good
for nobody who wins
you know how long did it take you to
come to that I mean just cuz you have to
analyze a certain situation for a long
enough to come up with conclusion like
that I don't think the analyze the
situation that long ly just oh this
sucks I'm a comic on news right away mmm
was right away once I understood the
parameters was happening and I saw I
want to go watch some of the criticism
videos I was like what do people
criticize me from my plate okay cuz
everyone sent me that video of her like
when she first came out her monologue
and everyone's oh man how could she make
someone your race jokes hockey bra go to
open mic and go see someone do something
for the first time that's what you're
gonna see yeah but she got writers
so if the writers are of open-mike trash
they're gonna write some trash stuff to
it is what it is so just think about
this more that's all I wanted to say
yeah
[Music]